official drink of a guy
smoking a parliament light outside of a
rehab looking at
someone else and going listen man it's
gonna be different
this time that is exactly the official
drink
like i'm focused i have focus it's like
it's a skinny white kid using the word
focus who's still got the taste of that
chalky cocaine in his throat and he's
like
i'm focused bro i just gotta [ __ ]
stick with it this time
you gotta bro
get your life together touch me bro i'm
not touching you dude
tell her meet me at [ __ ] 250. chelsea
is the best version of me
yeah she's jim dylan's final form
i agree i grow into chelsea lit at the
end
you thank you as goro at the end from
district 12 it is
tim trailer trash tammy i love it
what happened to uh the little the
little twink asian you had
the second day he comes to work he
brings an assist and he said this is my
assistant
[ __ ] yeah yeah hell yeah well they're
all on drugs the kids
well they're just asians gay asians
around drugs oh really
yeah like molly yeah they're on a lot of
drugs molly adderall crystal meth
oh wow yeah even in nashville oh yeah
they make it there they have the barns
they have the space that makes sense
theo hired one yeah a lot of the barrels
are here
yeah right yeah the methamphetamine i've
seen
you can see it when you drive by certain
areas you can smell it you can see them
almost out there in the fields like
just with the blow dryers on the barrels
you know now jelly roll might be the
head chef out there for all that [ __ ]
though
yeah i don't look he doesn't strike me
as a chef he definitely strikes me as
somebody who
dines though
[Laughter]
do you know jelly roll at all no jelly
roll at all oh you guys would get along
jesus christ
he's a rapper white rapper out there big
jelly roll i love i just remember
everything i've heard so far i like yeah
[Music]
brendan you look good you look like a
[ __ ] hitman for a hype church brendan
[Laughter]
there's jelly rolls jelly roll how's he
doing you know
oh he's uh his doctor told me he can't
drink anymore because that's not an
option he was right if you're gonna
drink he has to be tequila
so he stays why why can't he drink liver
uh yeah
but few health problems with my boy
brendan looks like a [ __ ] trans
sofa cushion if you look at him
this girl's bad oh that's jelly roll
you look like you're doing well theo out
there your outfit looks like you're
having no problems
you look thank you man life's good i'm
doing golf later on so you look like
you're gonna break into
church you look like a youth minister
who takes it very seriously
and uh everyone's a little uncomfortable
we love you jesus christ yeah like
you're getting in everyone's face
it's a little early in the morning for
that level of intensity several of them
we really want the kids have a
relationship with god but is this
completely
this energy neces we need right yeah you
look like carl lentz's [ __ ]
spiritual advisor yeah yeah i used that
joke last week brendan and
you look tim looks like somebody who
wishes he hadn't agreed to this a few
weeks ago
that's not true i look like i look like
i look like chelsea lynn's husband
[Laughter]
me and chelsea lynn would be the most
popular couple at golden corral
yeah come to our table like they were
talking to the godfather
[Music]
tim how are you feeling man now that do
you think it's a coincidence
trump gets banned from twitter and
social media and you get banned from
airbnb i was banned from airbnb
i went to an airbnb in the desert uh two
uh
lesbians had uh uh you know
uh put together an airbnb with uh
furniture that no one could sit on
right like art pieces like i had fat
people with me so they couldn't sit in
the chairs
or anything we all had to just stand out
there in the middle of the desert it was
really embarrassing and uh we left some
dishes in the sink that's all we did
didn't break anything i mean look at
this look at that that's what you had to
sit on
every piece of furniture like sodomized
you as you sat on it like that's how
[ __ ] up it was look at that
that's a chair it's ridiculous so then
these lesbians uh
i i threatened to kill them i texted
them i said i was gonna burn down your
house
they said are you threatening me i said
let's just see what happens uh i then
texted him i said let the games begin
ladies you have no idea who you're
[ __ ] with
then uh airbnb kicked me off
now did they file a formal complaint or
did everybody imagine
i heard you follow the story i imagine
these because i spoke about it on my
podcast i said i wanted to gas them
locked them in their house
gassed them and watched them like like
pour out the windows like cats
very much like the patriot have you seen
that scene in the patriot yes
that's what i want thank you yeah so
that's where we're at with that i am
removed from airbnb
but uh i will set up my producer we'll
just set it up under his account and
i'll use vrbo
i don't give a [ __ ] and uh you know you
know those ladies you know watch your
back
put your back have the fans been
harassing them do we know their profiles
and [ __ ] probably i don't know what my
fans
i don't know what people do i don't know
if they're sending messages
but they had to go private on instagram
and they had to
uh you know turn off comments on the
page because
they trashed me on a public forum which
is airbnb and i am just using
my opportunity as a citizen of this
country your voice to speak freely
against these two lesbians who are
not designers not artists not
interesting uh they are
uh goofy [ __ ] and you know we're
we're locked in a war
[ __ ] airbnb too and [ __ ] airbnb they're
not letting the terrorists
stay in the airbnbs they want to do the
civil war for the inauguration yeah
that's [ __ ] good
they want to play the terrorists want to
pay the money look i grew up
around a lot of cwrs man and we used to
go and you know we'd picnic out there
and eat at them
and watch the battles you know and so
you know it's not surprising
that a lot of those guys are still left
and they want to you know
get out and about and they have that
energy inside of them right but um
and that's civil war you mean civil war
reenactments like that's who's coming
out
to like climb in the capital dudes that
are like out there totally fields yeah
yeah take it a little too serious it
didn't go well and also
look a lot of yeah there's a lot of you
know lesbians with the expendable income
and they're doing the extra home
you know when they have the they call
them the deckless angry a lot
that's what it is no lesbians are
they're very angry and they take every
job they do seriously
even if it's the worst job in the world
a lesbian
pretends like she's like the national
security advisor so
she could be restocking vending machines
and she acts like it's the most
essential critical job ever being
performed uh
and it's just their power obsessed you
know beasts really why why do you think
you have issues with lesbians do you
think you would have issues if they were
just i live with gay to gay men too i
have issues with straight people i just
i have issues with people that don't
respect me and these two their names are
jonah and mila
can you imagine jonah and mila
how do you respect their airbnb photo is
them sitting with their weimaraner in
like big hats
are they hot like i do not feel like
they're hot no but
i i just i just don't i don't want to
get too much trouble here because i
probably will get a letter from a lawyer
within a day or two
their dog is probably named elizabeth
smart they always have a dog that's
named
after like a you know someone like you
know someone that's been through a lot
you know yeah we're just over i'm over
the whole lesbian attitude of like very
serious severe
like we're very competent and we have
good credit it's like
who gives a [ __ ] you're going to hell
like everyone else yep
theo you have any issues with lesbian or
are they all good with you because you
look like them
first of all brendan uh you look like a
[ __ ] get it out buddy i don't have it
that's the problem i've used it all on
so many episodes of this show
but i do want to say yes i i i feel like
i'm okay with lesbians man but i'm never
look i'll be honest my first interaction
with lesbians we had a couple lesbians
live across the street from us
and they used to try to sync their
lights up with the uh
with the radio station and they couldn't
make it happen and it was
crunch time it was christmas eve and
they ended up fist fighting in the yard
and one of them worked at the library
and uh and ever since then and i did
donuts in their [ __ ] yard a couple
days later and ever since then we've
been on the rocks but
what gets me is why lesbians are so
angry at straight men
and i think that tim is just you know
like
there's a lot of you know there's a lot
of you know chatter on the dark web and
stuff these days if t
where's tim sexuality even lie so i i
don't even think they looked at you
i think i thought i think they looked at
you as like uh
you know um tom cruise's [ __ ] yeah
they looked at me
i do have a wife and kids i don't think
there's a problem with that
i identify i identify as gay
in this community that we're in i do
have a wife and kids that live in
suburban new jersey
i own a family-style italian restaurant
and uh it's called rigatoni's and we're
very happy
but uh as a as when i live in l.a i'm a
a homosexual
and i'm gonna come out as trans very
soon that's coming
but no these lesbians looked at me as a
straight man uh a grotesque middle
american straight male pig
who defiled their [ __ ] art piece in
jewel box in the desert
and the reality is uh that i expose them
as frauds
and i've done it to the world now i've
exposed them as frauds
as these cause that's what lesbians are
they're talentless
men that's what they are no offense to
them there for the most most of them are
are grunting tim allen yeah you know
home improvement pigs and i've exposed
them is that you can put on anything
you want i know what you are you're a
demon from hell
so when i come out and tell everyone in
the world that i can't go to airbnb
anymore and that's not right
that's not right do you think they're
gonna catch on to you know how trump got
banned from twitter so he started
using another account do you think
they're gonna ban your producer dude now
it's gonna [ __ ] it up
i don't give a [ __ ] i've got a legion of
patriots i call my fans the patriots
and i mean airbnb has a headquarters i'm
sure
we'd love to get in there with some
vikings
and let everybody know what's going on
do they advertise on the show i don't
care
uh we'd like to go over to airbnb say
hello to everybody let them know how we
feel
send me in i'll shawshank through the
damn [ __ ] pipe daddy send me in yeah
ethiopian
leader there yeah i'll send theo right
in i'll come out two months later
into the wrong office i'll show up in a
[ __ ] dunkin donuts and put a brush
t-shirt on hey as long as people get
scared the point of terror is always
terror yeah
so as long as people get scared that's
fine san fran that's the easy drive for
you and the
in the uh of course sure it's
headquartered in san fran and the two
legends got kicked
out things are connecting in my head now
things are starting to make sense
yeah and what i don't like about today's
lesbians and i'm going to say i'm going
to go up and straight up and say it is
when i was young a lot of lesbians knew
about um
astronomy you know it was their big
thing it was like you know they're
this the the last star you know the
[ __ ] stardust of christ and all this
[ __ ]
and now they don't even [ __ ] know
their they don't even know their roots
anymore it's just yeah it's a lot of
arrogance
it's a lot of coffee table books and
hard [ __ ] yeah
[Laughter]
when i grew up lesbians knew about cars
they knew about shortwave radios
they were they were creatures from
stephen king novels and they
embraced and they used to communicate
like the movie frequency
with other [ __ ] dimensions true to
shortwave radio
tell me about your life i'm a cop now
lesbians they don't know how to do that
it's all frozen yogurt and eating puss
yeah that's it dude and yeah yeah
[Laughter]
it's gotten sad dude and a lot of them
are even putting drop like uh
they'll throw a damn downy dryer sheet
into their [ __ ] just to tighten it up
absolutely and i don't and i don't like
it i hate it when my wife does it
yeah me too man oh brenda you look like
a [ __ ] sous chef at a meth lab dude
tim looks like his shirt cannot ever
decide what size it is
but tim we're happy you're here today
man thank you so much for coming in and
uh
and helping fill in for us man my shirt
size is uh it's king size because it's
from a catalog
so whatever size it is it's for a kid
okay it's called king size uh that's a
catalog
thank you your shirt looks like it rapes
those untucked
shirts you know things you know things
are going well when you're shopping at a
catalog yeah things are going really
well
when you're now shopping you have to
open your mail to shop
[Laughter]
the most important thing in life is
sleep man
and with everything going on today
politics your relationship
the drama going on in your life you need
good sleep and it all starts with your
mattress if you got a
bad mattress you're not sleeping right
you're not relaxing you're not fresh for
the day so i got some for you how about
helix sleep
and it's so easy man they got the
perfect mattress just for your thick ass
helix sleep has a quiz that takes two
minutes to complete
and they match you with your body type
and the perfect mattress just for you
not all bodies are built the same not
all matches are built the same
that's why there's helix sleep it was
even awarded the number one best overall
mattress
of 2019 2020 by gq and wired magazine
my house has them i can't get rid of
people because they want to sleep there
my father-in-law has back pain not when
he sleeps at my house because of helix
sleep
go to helixsleep.com kats take the
two-minute sleep quiz
they'll match you with a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life
they have a 10 year warranty and you get
to try it for 100 nights risk free they
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it but you will
helix is offering you guys up to 200 off
all mattress orders and free pillows
for the king and sting listeners helix
sleep.com k-a-t-s
that's helix sleep.com k-a-t-s for up to
200
off listen you know manscape makes the
best
below the waist grooming products did
you know they just dropped their new
cologne yeah
that's right big news manscape just
released the new clone scent to help you
feel good
and smell good all over your body
everybody knows that manscape has the
perfect package 3.0
for all your below the waist grooming
needs but they didn't stop
there they went what else can we do how
about cologne
perfect a reef defined cologne signature
scent
by manscaped is fantastic chicks dig it
dudes dig it dogs dig it
cats dig it your mom's gonna dig it
everybody loves it manscape
knocked out the park with this all right
uh check out the perfect package
three-pointer with all the essentials
for below the waist grooming
as well all right talk about lawnmower
3.0 trimmer
all right the crop formulations yes i'm
talking about the ball deodorant i put
it between my thighs and grab my bike
because i'm thick
and you can use the new manscape
redefine clone to complete your set
and smell great anytime anywhere it's
time to smell right get 20
off and free shipping with code
kingsting at manscape.com
your balls and body will thank you get
20 percent off and free shipping with
code kingsting
manscape.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com
use code kingston look good smell good
feel good with manscape oh it's getting
good dude what's this jumping
nick i thought we'd uh kick it off with
uh this guy he's kind of shooting his
shot with brendan
uh he's with me trying to [ __ ] brandon
uh i respect that uh
unless he might be using code he didn't
say do you have an airbnb right
what's up king and their sting
what's up feel looking for adorable
what's up
nick china cat shout out culture corner
shout out muscular tyler the creator
over there
looking more like tyler the creatine
chappelle
i am shooting my shot with you brendan
the sharbosaurus rex
i am a male massage therapist how did
you got
beef with male massage therapist man so
let me change your mind
i should be seeing you in april in
newcastle meet my wife
and i'll roll up with all my gear dude
i'll give you the best back massage of
your life
yeah gang gang foot rub
well let him tickle you that is enticing
he's from the pamper lounge yeah i don't
i don't know man prefer female masseuse
i like them big too big russians breathe
hard
take all the oxygen in the room uh
i just not it's hard for me to relax the
male masseuse now
theo hires some poor asian feller
and pays him forty dollars to do god
knows what to him every time he's in l.a
tell me oh you gotta try this out man 40
[ __ ] dollars theo
you cheap those guys are named bk and pk
and off of westwood boulevard and that's
siri foot spa and they're shut down
right now because of the damn disease
but i will say this when i first got to
town they had a couple vietnamese guys
for 60
would beat the [ __ ] out of you in one of
those dog bite suits downtown
and it no joke bro i remember it was
good
he does he doesn't he finished by doing
like a backflip on your
ass or something like that though no he
would backflip and land right at the
[ __ ] small of your back
and you could barely feel him forty
dollars man chris christ bro
you go to the uh spa tim you might have
not
i mean i used to go get a massage but
now we can't
i mean you could have somebody coming
back with bieber who you responded with
huh
you there with trey songz who the [ __ ]
you spying with big dog
well i go to spa with a lot of different
people and yes most of them are
rappers or athletes and i don't want to
make you jealous but
that is a community that i find myself
in and the community that appreciates
what i do
i know you hang out with jeremy shockey
i know the kind of [ __ ] guys you hang
out with yeah
it's just it's just uh what a reference
yeah
jeremy what a old school rep just pulls
it right out
uh no i i i would like to have a guy
come to the house and do massages you do
that that'd be good
i'm just not trying to go to like i
don't want to go to like
you know like korea town and like get
massaged in a chicken coop
i'd rather like go have someone come to
my house
asians are the safest way to go though
may him walk on your back feed you a
little soup
oh yeah dude don't hide under your arm i
don't need to be a scene from the golden
child i just want to feel better theo
goes forty dollars a little soup a
little walk on the back kicking the nuts
you know what i mean i should fear used
to do all the time we used to go to like
schwitz
at the at the uh the us like the um
yeah the steam rooms in new york city
yeah the russian bass the turkish bats
you ever go to those it's just like fat
old russian dudes like
sitting and it's just so hot and crazy
though you got to watch your words yeah
on there you got you because you know
it's tough but you can only use the n
word in there i know that dude that is
inward
central you can drop it wherever you
want in that joke that is a word that is
very welcome there yeah
you can use that yeah it's not frowned
upon there it's not frowned upon at all
nobody's getting canceled
they say it when you walk in they just
look at you they say n word and you have
to say
you have to say and that's how you uh
granted that's how they know you're okay
yeah it's like when ants touch their
tentacles together exactly
that's good now tim a lot of what i've
seen of you with the i want to go back
to this airbnb
were you doing fancy meals at these
places because a lot of times i was
doing a very
traditional meal we had burgers i make a
signature burger which is a martin
potato roll
uh a burger a sauteed onions barbecue
sauce and american cheese but i sauteed
the cheese in the onions
so it becomes like a cheese sauce it's
stupidly good sign me up
we did that we did baked beans in a pot
and the beans do explode at a certain
heat that's not my fault that's science
and we did gordon's fish you know the
planks of gorton's fish
trusted gordon's fishermen those are
fish plants gordon's fish and tartar
sauce
so it smelled very pungent it was very
strong smell
and and we did with then we got a bunch
of pints of ice cream to have like a
tasting of ice creams
uh and then um you know but again i'm
paying a 400
airbnb cleaning fee so why aren't you
cleaning the [ __ ] thing
get paid 400 [ __ ] dollars clean the
[ __ ] airbnb
what is the deal now with the cleaning
people having attitudes at the airbnb
yeah you know it's crazy some lady
wanted me to help her
uh they didn't she didn't have windex or
anything she was basically cleaning just
by
kind of sage i think she was using and
like a witch
yeah my maid is such a fat lazy
piece of [ __ ] she me and her will stand
in the kitchen and we're both eating
pumpkin loaf
and no one's doing anything i'm like i
just got another version of me
or and she talks on her phone all day
with her [ __ ] sister
is it a bluetooth yeah yeah she's on her
bluetooth all day with her sister like
she's scamming and scheming and her
sisters have van eyes and they're
they're trying to [ __ ] figure [ __ ]
out she's always like my husband's a
gardener you should use him i'm like
[ __ ] you don't even do the job you're
here to do
and she just walked i don't think she
cleans out she just walks around for
three hours
and then leaves but what do i know i
don't want to i don't want to be called
racist so i just give her money
yeah oh i tell people i'm racist
straight up right when i meet him these
days i'm tired of [ __ ]
you know i'm tired of them fine you know
i'm tired of it leaking later
right right you just want to be honest
i'm
i'm recovering racist anyway yeah
it makes sense you're in a 12-step
racist program theo
yeah i'm on about the third step and let
me just say there's a lot of brothers on
the stoop you know what i'm saying man
so that's all i'm saying
what else you got nick uh speaking of
recovery uh this
let's do some debate club all right
what's up fellas
i am from walla walla washington
my name's alex i'm out here on walla
walla river just doing some
pheasant duck hunting floating around
having fun
burying my wife so my
debate club is which is harder to break
the habit of cigarettes or the habit of
that nography man you know the dirty
dirty interwebs
and we all know riley mal's a liar he
says he doesn't struggle with it
he's a little liar so yeah that's my uh
that's my debate club so it's gang buzz
buzz
porn or cigarettes yeah harder to quit
cigarettes
cigarettes are much harder when you want
to be quick
unless you're a [ __ ] psychopath like
i mean i think i think cigarettes are
much harder because you can get
stimulated sexually
all kinds of different ways but
cigarettes man i've given up everything
i've given up cocaine
morphine methadone percocet demerol
[ __ ] you know ecstasy shrooms uh
all that stuff all the good [ __ ] i
cigarettes are the hardest thing to not
[ __ ] want to do because you always
look at a cigarette and it looks good
it's a routine too right like the smoke
going into your lungs
i don't care about even smoking during
the day but yeah leave them alone
and you're in a nice backyard and you
just you're trying to talk to someone
and make a point
having a cigarette just gives you
something which gives you something man
i'm struggling with alcohol i'm 12 days
clean now i'm taking january off and
last night i was jonesing man it's tough
god it's
terrible i think we froze
yeah theo froze or he's very committed
to this
i was watching the whole thing it's
you can text people and have them send
you videos of them doing dirty things
you're right
is that porn uh yeah that's a version of
it
to my girlfriend that's poor i said to
my girlfriend that's
that's considered porn well of course if
you're not interested
if you say to somebody hey send me a
video of you doing something
is that porn yes is it pornographic
material
it depends it's just not they're just
not if it's somebody you care about it
might not be but i think if you're just
getting some random stranger and they're
just
hitchhiking in their own butt with their
thumbs then yeah i think it is no
i'm talking about you meet someone
online and you go i'll give i'll venmo
you seventy five dollars
for you to do something on camera and
then send it to me that's paul
that's big business yeah that's that's
porn that's jerry from [ __ ]
the documentary the the cheer
documentary he's in prison for it
but that's child porn yeah i'm talking
about adults
what kind of that's the craziest thing
yeah you're right that's the craziest
thing i've ever heard of my point
he's like well actually what that
actually is is uh
we'll send you to jail not if they're of
age
completely but that would be considered
porn right because you're receiving
pornographic material yeah you're right
from not from a professional that you're
right it's amateur porn that
but i'm directing it and telling them
what to do
that to me feels more like an organics
you know we're saying you got to cut out
all that i feel oh
yeah that's hard but cigarettes are so
hard in small business small business
what he's talking about brand yeah i'm
talking about a startup
where i have a gofundme yeah it's a
startup where i'm trying to direct
people and help
yeah it's like directing through text
messages basically a lot of people say
porn's harder to quit but they've never
smoked cigarettes or they have they've
never had nicotine i'm gonna take they
uh like i won't smoke all day and then
it's just that night
at night sometimes you're sitting in my
backyard and you're just looking at owls
yeah you just i've seen your backyard
too man it's a smoker's yard yeah your
yard makes me want to smoke it's a
smoker you just sit out there and you
see an owl in the desert and you see a
little bunny hop by and you just
smoke a cigarette and you talk about
queueing on that's right
that's where i struggle at night man i
want to drink at night
it's tough dude night's tough i was just
in vegas it's so hard
what the [ __ ] were you doing vegas i
wanted to go to dinner
yeah i want to go to dinner and i can't
go to dinner in the state of california
so where do where'd you go in vegas we
went to the win
and i went to minami sushi restaurant
there and i went to carbon in the aria
come on and yeah it was great you're
living brother i'm just trying man we
went to vegas
now carbone is that that lady's
restaurant gia what's her name
no that's chiata's is called giadas in
vegas
yeah the attractive woman who pretends
to be a chef
yeah she's kind of yes it's definitely
the the allure is
leaving i think a lot of people are
going back to their grassroots of foods
i'm finding you know
theo you struggle a little bit with a
little
in england they call him a [ __ ] the
cigarettes brendan
yeah yeah the last [ __ ] i'm dealing with
is in this room and it ain't you timmy
i'll tell you that
hey thank you so much here's what i'm
saying is
i don't even know what i'm [ __ ]
saying dude what is this native american
asking about
what's up gang listen all right i have a
king in this thing for y'all okay
so doing my job
i shot up the oven in nashville but
doing my job i travel a lot
um and with that i miss out on a lot of
family time a lot of
you know friend time people that i know
clothes you know
that living back at home and i don't get
to spend any time with them
and i know you guys deal with the same
[ __ ] being that you guys go on the road
and do shows and
it usually works out because it's better
pay right so that's my question is it
better just to stay home
find work and just struggle if you have
to or is it better
to travel miss out on family time but
get better pay
um yeah get gang buzz buzz [ __ ]
[ __ ]
we start with brendan here because
brendan's missed half of his children's
life to be [ __ ] performing in boise
next week so what do you say brendan
yeah that's true yeah the pandemic made
me realize i tore too much man so i cut
it down to two weekends a month
moving forward i just do three to four
right
so i cut it down to two so i'm around my
kids more but theo you don't have to
i mean you just own a [ __ ] backpack
so you can tour all year
long yeah that's true man you're right i
think what this guy is saying is first
of all i like where this guy's at this
is the kind of guy you need help with
we don't need to be storming a capital
we need a storm a t and t
we need a storm [ __ ] right dunkin
donuts headquarters we need a storm
zabarro we need a store
tech is the new fossil fuels guys okay
and so we need to be storming places
that it hits them in the wallet god this
guy's question is
should he look into work or raise his
family
oh yeah my bad sorry i kind of diverted
what do you say there that's his
question should he work or raise his
family
yeah well i would think that he could
maybe both
yes i mean that might be a good idea
like this guy i think
i think he wants us to co-sign his
decision of like just abandoning his
family
so he could [ __ ] pick cell phone
towers i'm like
dude you gotta check in on the fam every
now and then you know
yeah maybe i'm chilling the craziest
it's the craziest question i've ever
heard he's like
hey guys uh i i work
a lot and i travel i want to know do i
still have to talk to my family
it's like yeah i'm putting up all these
5g towers man
i've seen my son in three years yeah do
i technically have to
like see and speak to my family i mean i
have a job
i have a job why would i yeah dude do
both
yeah that's not a bad thought that's a
decent suggestion tim
tim also i just realized looks like the
poseidon of [ __ ] key west florida
right now
let me tell you right now there's no
place i'd rather be sitting there
uh eating a conch fritter uh drinking a
don julio blanco white tequila on the
rocks
and uh just sitting there and uh talking
about a marina that i wish i had the
balls to burn down
because they [ __ ] me over on a boat
slip
yeah literally where i want to be i
would turn to somebody
i'd be smoking a cigarette and i'd be
like they gave the last slip away i said
if i was more of a man i'd go down there
and i burned that [ __ ] thing down
myself
[Laughter]
i'm in brother yeah i think for this
young fellow man you gotta if you have a
family bro you gotta see them man and
also if you're a t you can build a
landline right to your house so then no
matter where you are at work
you could clock in be right there with
your kids
and that's digital that's all digital
wireless built from the ground up bro
good evening everybody let's say this if
you sell stuff online you know it's
tricky
you know you got to get the sale you got
to get the item you got to get it out
confusing you don't know what's going on
sometimes you don't know who you are you
don't know
you know you're sad and you're at your
house or something like that but what
i'm talking about now is that uh
what i'm telling you about here is um
what is this company called
ship station ship station brings all
your orders into one
simple interface making them really easy
to manage from any device
even your phone i don't care what it is
a phone a falcon if you've got a damn
baby's back and uh
you know and an etch a sketch you can
handle it
ship station allows you to ship things
no matter whether you're using usps
fedex and ups
everything's online now if you want a
little something you get it online you
want that you get it online
you want a milk you want a car ticket to
the carnival
you do it online baby you need to do it
now
ship station offers big discounts on
shipping rates any business can access
the same discounts
that are usually reserved for big
fortune 500 companies
that's right every company is as
important as the big ones
there's a good reason that ship station
is the number one choice of online
sellers get 2021 off to a great start by
visiting shipstation.com just use our
offer code
kats to get a 60 day free trial
shipping that's two months free of no
hassle stress
free shipping just go to ship
shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the page and type in k-a-t-s
that's shipstation.com enter offer code
k-a-t-s
ship station make ship happen what's up
kids and killers baby it's that little
bluetooth daddy you feel me
it's that hard penis ninja dog you know
what i'm talking about that hpn
though and i'm here to tell you about
blue chews baby
you know there's been times you're
outdoors you're running around you don't
know what's going on but you know your
dick ain't good
well let's change it up it only takes a
few minutes to connect
with the bluechew.com affiliated
position
and if you qualify you get prescribed
online quickly
no in-person doctor visit no awkward
conversation hey what are you here for
what do you
i don't know i've just wandered into the
wrong place i'm just looking for
directions yeah me too i don't know my
wife
it only takes a few minutes the
chewables from bluetooth.com are made in
the usa none of them foreign
hitters you and your partner will love
it chew it and do it
here's a great deal for you guys visit
bluechew.com and get your first order
free
when you use promo code kats just pay
five dollars shipping that's b-l-u-e
c-h-e-w dot com promo code k-a-t-s
uh we've got a sync my inc we're gonna
look at some people's tattoos and you
guys uh let us know what you think
this guy looks like he's about to show
us his dick
whatever brandon what up theo this is
nick from knoxville tennessee got a
little sync my ink for you
my wife she likes those personal name
and today we got married hitters
me myself i like that buzz buzz
damn and that rat king that red king
also got the kids initials on here's tim
the fourth one is for the one that's on
its way
so in honor of that damn he's been
[ __ ] huh
baby season oh damn good baby season
the the king of the sting tats were dope
the rest of them look like straight off
ed hardy
yeah i mean the rest of them are prison
yeah tattoos and i'm i'm i'm not wrong
on that right
old sailor tats yeah i mean he's a
beautiful young man right here with his
family what's what advice you have for
this family moving forward you feel like
tim
bringing a new child into the world well
you know i i i
i think that it it they seem happy and
they seem
like they're fans and they seem like
good people
uh statistically it's gonna be a rough
road but
i mean if you look at the data and the
facts and the numbers not all of those
kids
are going to make it to where they want
to go uh you just hope let's just say
this you just hope that
whatever happens it happens quickly
you know i'd rather uh ferris wheel
accident than nine years of a heroin
addiction where i have to barricade
myself in the bathroom
because my son is banging on it trying
to steal my back medication so
yeah just hope one day one of them
crosses the street and it's over quickly
well that's positive yeah thank you for
listening
no but i love that and thank you tim for
being honest the last thing you want is
to be sitting there [ __ ] eating a can
of baked beans while your
kid spends his last 12 dollars on
[ __ ] pain pills making interventional
audition tapes
how many people don't make it on
intervention bro uh
dude where the intervention out the the
ones that didn't make yeah the outdated
why haven't you made that video
please make that video for us my
favorite show when i was on drugs and
drunk was to watch intervention it makes
you feel better about it makes you feel
good because you're like
no one no one's getting me yet yeah
that's why i like 600 pound life
makes me feel good dude darren aronofsky
has a new movie coming out called the
whale about a guy who's 600 pounds can't
leave his house
and everybody's mad at him about it and
they're all trying to cancel him
because they're like oh what is it not
healthy to be 600 pounds
so that's that i'm excited about that
man
uh do you feel like airbnb tried to
cancel you tim do you feel like
i believe that what's going on behind
the scenes right now at a lot of these
tech companies is that there
is unfortunately a they're reactionary
they're just like they're just basically
doing things without thinking about it
there's no due process
i can't defend myself i'm given a very
general and vague
um you know like if they had said to me
like hey you threatened to kill those
two women
i would go all right that is on me but
they didn't even do that
they just bear they're like bro you
threatened to burn a house down i'd go
well hey i get it i i was to defend
myself
you know uh that i was speaking
metaphorically and i was you know being
a
comedian um but they're not even doing
that they're saying i
like very vague guidelines i don't even
know what they are that i violated it's
like
yeah you know it's just yeah you were up
too late in the pool and you're like
didn't even have a [ __ ] pool
yeah i mean at the end of the day
i will kill both of these women
and i i mean that's just what i'll say
still give him five stars
right i gave him five stars i'm not a
rat they texted me
they texted me and said give us a good
review they said the cleaning lady is a
little unhappy
well hope you had a good time give us a
good review so we stay on airbnb
they're not allowed to do that i i gave
them a good review because i'm not a rat
okay they then ratted on me and now
they've opened the gates of hell
i'll show up with the with the with the
westboro baptist church to the airbnb
the bc baby that's like the untouchables
dude this is kind of like the
untouchables meets
weekend at bernie's i feel like it's a
war and would you say game on hoes
i i said i texted them yesterday as soon
as i got banned from airbnb i said
uh i'll tell you exactly what i say
welcome to the game yeah i said
i said uh this is just the beginning
welcome to the game
hell yeah so i mean i hope that you know
they understand what they've done and
that they've awakened
like a sleeping uh giant oh yeah they go
is that a threat
yeah i'm like we'll see what happens
yeah they're probably
it's they're probably sitting in a
garden somewhere teaching classical
violin to each other's vulvas right here
yeah that's exactly what they're doing
and i just want to let them know that
like accidents happen
all the time man baby properties burn
down people get in car
accidents people have weird prescription
drug interactions
people just end up dead on kitchen
floors and no one knows
why yep accidentally anthraxing via
drone
right that's the whole thing they could
go to get a coven vaccine and find out
it wasn't
i don't know uh
let's move on to another sink by ink
wait did we help that last guy oh is
that his tattoos look good
congratulations on the family brother
that's beautiful
it's good to know a lot of men are out
there and still have deep work working
semen a lot of men do not
you included uh
i would i would bet the under on myself
on my own seed
yeah if you had anything yet deal you
might want to look at anything again
swim or swim one one scare in north
dakota
yeah i did have a scare with a native
american girl years ago who won it who
immediately after engagement uh
you know was said she would have the
child i'm like
and it was a layover flight i'm like i'm
not being a layover
dad you know like i'll be a direct
flight dad but i'm not being a layover
you know i'm going to pay my taxes
you're going to get your money through
the government or whatever we're going
to [ __ ] call it a wrap you know
what layover is in north dakota it was
through st louis she drove 11 hours to
meet me from st
louis from a uh reservation good on her
man
it was a uh it was a hyatt select or one
of those hyatt
like the bootleg hyatt kind of hey the
height uh the height
um height or something
it's like i'll tell you what i don't
know what the betting odds on that baby
having a drinking problem but pretty hot
yeah and then she drove off into the
night and then i almost got worried that
she was going to kill my
son bro she had just driven 11 hours
oh those are different times is there is
there an indian theo
out there or what little black foot
roaming the streets i hope so bro
i hope so man uh let's see what brian
has to say
i like how nick just said he's told
about that okay
what's up brian and leon coming straight
out of dallas texas had to sneak away
from work
to make this video hopefully i don't get
fired but
if i made it on the show it'll be worth
it so what do you think about this
dude's tattoo a little sink my ink
does he look like the hardest guy at a
taylor swift concert
or does he look like a guy at the bottom
of a mosh pit
at a taylor swift concert shout out to
my boy theo i saw you a couple years ago
at the addison improv
hooked me up with a selfie shout out to
my girl kat
about a year ago i slid in mdm's
confessing my love for you
still ain't heard of response it's all i
love and it's all good
gang gang but fuzz
gang gang baby thank you brian for the
submission and this is
obviously a cry for help
what's great is not only the monster
tattoo but the the asks that you learn
how to make when you're in fourth grade
you see that like ass that you draw on
marble notebooks in the back of
chemistry class
yeah man like that trapper keeper yeah
whatev right on a trapper keeper
like i don't even know i don't know what
the what the rationale behind the s is
but
also how much monster do you have to
drink to put a corporate sponsor do you
think that's a real tattoo or do you
think that's like a thing with marker
ah can we zoom in on that nick and it's
red as [ __ ] it looks pretty yeah it's
probably attacking the official
i feel like that's everything yeah
he's all red around it it looks uh looks
real have you guys heard that uh monster
is like
a satanic drink these are supposed to be
like
the three dashes are like the six letter
they mean like six
in hebrew or something and it's supposed
to be the market
shocked by this dude how sad would it be
if satan came back to earth he's like
all right so who's
how are we keeping my name alive they're
like uh
well there's a few aspiring dj's
drinking a drink
that has to do with you he's like what
he's like so
what have we been doing they're like we
got a shitty energy drink
that uh you know is sponsoring uh you
know
professional skateboarders professor
skateboarders and me yeah i was
sponsored by monster for i don't know
four years well the satan would be very
disappointed in that by the way
satan's like who are we working with
maniscalco we got
ck they're like nah we're supporting we
got brendan
all right whatever man oh the official
drink of ptsd right there
that's a ptsd smoothie everybody that
has ptsd
drinks monster bro yeah there's
definitely a correlation there
those are monster objects official drink
of a guy
smoking a parliament light outside of a
rehab looking at
someone else and going listen man it's
gonna be different
this time that is exactly the official
drink
like i'm focused i have focus it's like
it's a skinny white kid using the word
focus who still got the taste of that
chalky cocaine in his throat and he's
like
i'm focused bro i just gotta [ __ ]
stick with it this time
you gotta have bro you gotta go
monster is basically [ __ ] hard syrup
[Laughter]
yeah
all right [ __ ] is [ __ ] give it to
your children
people that's what we need give it to
your [ __ ] children yeah
and then mail them to nancy pelosi what
do we have to do
uh let's move on some kinder stinger hey
what's up guys i'm a big fan of the show
and i draw from time to time so
i want to know your real opinion on fan
art is it weird is it creepy
let me know can you understand it gang
gang buzz buzz
that's bad man especially especially if
you're talented this dude
i got some beautiful fan art of me and
uh my friend who's a cat
uh and it's gorgeous fan art dude like
so is that oscar
yeah oscar yeah i mean i got some fan
art uh i i'm a big fan of the fan art if
it's done well
sometimes fans will just send me like a
circle with little feet and a head
and it says timmy d i don't love that
put a little effort into it yeah so let
me send me that nick
text me that will do and then yeah
that's beautiful man who is this artist
nick can you can you shout out
he's good yeah this is diego loya
from lindsay california diego loya
that's beautiful man wow here's the rat
king one
oh that's dope off the top rope yeah
that's really dope it's great
i gotta get off twitter twitter it's
become the hampton it's not even it's
like the ramada of basically of
liberals social media your twitter is
getting real
bad it's getting pretty toxic everybody
on twitter is upset about something
like everything you say on twitter
there's 20 people
fighting about it like it's it's so
stupid it's like
it's not healthy there's no good will on
twitter anymore like no good will you
could be like
you'd be like hey man uh i've got cancer
and the first response is hey [ __ ] you
you're like dude what
happened to the site you know twitter's
the monster energy drink of social media
that's exactly right
oh good call brendan wow brendan uh more
kinger stingets
theo shaw brandon vaughn what up this is
tyler from virginia
beach big fan i got a king of her sing
it or maybe even a rip my drift for you
you decide the 80s are coming back
that's why everyone's rocking these
ridiculous ass sunglasses right
so i got one for you brandon you're all
about that high fashion that's why you
stay rocking that romper right
so how you feel about dudes bringing it
back bringing back that
men's crop top
that half t-shirt hitter hit her baby
gang gang buzz buzz
ooh crop tops what do you think on this
man when you see this man
what do you think of this suck dick for
coke
that's not a gay man but he is sucked
dick for a gram of cocaine
so that is the perfect outfit on the
segway says hey
i'm not gay but i will suck in for coke
in virginia beach
so if you're a businessman and you're at
a convention somewhere in virginia
and you're staying at a hotel and you
find yourself on a certain website at a
certain hour of night
uh that guy's showing up to your hotel
room and uh you're gonna get to suck
this guy off
and you're gonna give him 200 and he's
going to leave
and he's going to go to [ __ ] uh
waffle house and just
[ __ ] live that's exactly what that
guy's life feels
and by the way if it isn't it should be
and it's tragic
it's said or if he's not doing that this
guy will give you a blow job with his
butthole i know that
i'm going to tell you speaking of wall
files i took my sister who hadn't seen
in a year and a half we met up at
walthouse over the holidays
and we sit in there we have some coffee
we finally order a woman comes over a
young woman of uh
different dialect maybe and she's like
we're like ordered
she's like can't you [ __ ] see the
chef quit a half hour ago we're like
oh [ __ ] oh no we can't we didn't notice
that
it's christmas eve we're sitting in here
and we're like well
do you know when she's gonna actually be
like well tiffany's outside of smoking
and she ain't [ __ ] happy right now
[Laughter]
well we'll wait we'll wait so we waited
bro but
um anyway yeah this guy uh definitely
looks like
um postmates for his own he looks like
postmates for his own
semen that's what he looks like yeah
i mean this is the definition of if that
was your son
oh dude if that was your son
let me tell you right now dude if that
was your son
and you had to look at that guy i'd
rather him storm the castle i mean the
level of drunk you would have to be i
mean just
down syndrome drunk like can't even feel
your spine drunk
every time you see that man that guy at
thanksgiving
l5s what i don't know dude yeah i agree
with you man
that guy look first of all i think the
guy's abused him like a nice guy
um beautiful young guy you know
obviously
trying to get through college trying to
make it after college maybe yeah
there's no way i don't think so he's
never gone anywhere near a college
uh just count down the days of spring
break yeah uh maybe
in best case he's in a technical school
by the side of a highway
best case he's learning to be an air
conditioning repairman
at a technical school which he hasn't
showed up to in two weeks
and his mother has left cell phone
messages saying we're [ __ ] paying for
this
quick paperwork yeah brett we're paying
for this are you doing okay
this is the type of guy that disappears
for a year he
he uploads song lyrics at 1am on
facebook
then everyone's like oh he's in trouble
the comments on the page are like where
are you he disappears for a year and
then he re-emerges
with a blurry photo of himself standing
on a hill and a bible quote
that's who this guy is
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] dude
bro this guy seems he seemed like he
could get a job
as a crystal ball at richard simmons
birthday party
that guy is not really doing too well
but he seems like a nice guy man and
look man we're happy he's getting a
video but
they send the video so we're kinging
crop tops it sounds like it's stinging
for now that's a question
you think king it brendan no sting sting
no crop top we'll pick one man [ __ ]
pick one there's only two of them i said
sting bro
okay i thought you said king my bad man
these speakers are bad uh let's see
let's see what this guy has to say what
up cats fam
quick king of the stinging for you um
ghosts at the comedy store
i'm currently watching the ghost
adventures episode and they're at the
comedy store so
yeah um you guys ever had anything
happen to you guys but
can you understand it
gang gang ghosts ghosts go on you guys
go first i i will say in terms of just
creepy
things i felt like a weird
like a banshee you know what a banshee
is yeah
it's like an irish like i felt like a
weird like feminine energy that was very
like chaotic and
and bad and dark and evil
uh that's when that was and it was it
was whitney cummings
so that's
you got to be very careful that's what
i'm saying
um look man there is well [ __ ]
everybody that worked there has died
recently i mean first of all jeff scott
died the gay you know semi-moderate dude
how did he die
who knows allegedly gay you know he was
alcoholic also
got aids once but his you know he was
doing good but he uh he died
how did he died it's so sad dude how did
he die
yeah he died about uh three days ago
about of what do we know what
no some people said it was broken heart
man honestly i mean this was his love i
mean for 25 years he was there
god [ __ ] i had no idea he was a nice guy
man he's part of comedy history too
really is i mean just man that hit me
hard man
uh yeah just heartbreaking that he
passed away man
and they don't know what he passed away
from no it could have been complications
from different
issues that he had going on but he such
a nice guy
yeah man he was a great dude so many
people that work there
should die and it's sad that this guy
died
you know it's always the wrong ones yeah
dang
but there's a lot of ghosts i mean
somebody killed themselves next door
because they didn't get paid over the
years what else happened yeah he jumped
off the
hotel next to it he was a comic yeah
people pissed off there's always a ghost
of all the comedians being owed money
that ghost is definitely milling around
right but we got another king their
stinger from this guy
hey boys i got a king in the sting for
you this is going to go for theo and
brendan
there's a gentleman named tim richmond
who used to rock a mullet for theo
and he drives for nascar fast cars with
brendan
anyways tim richmond and nascar they
were shooting a photo shoot
for all the top nascar drivers for a
publicity shot
so richmond pulls his front piece out
and puts it right by neil bonnett's head
for the picture
now this picture made it all through the
editorial services
and uh went on to a big huge poster
shipped all over the place
so king or sting it front piece photo
bomb
buzz buzz dick pic wow what an epic dick
pic is this in the 90s or some [ __ ]
that guy's a gangster though he's right
over here the black guy just pulled out
his big black dick
it's on the left side i think zoom in
over there a little yeah i'm trying it's
right by
the guy's ear
what a legendary
right there and the fact that they
printed it everywhere what a legend
right it's a real hobby that's a good
thing i'll tell you i'll share a story i
was at uh this thing called beta
breakers one time up in san francisco
which is basically
become really the uh it's really the
i want to say it's become the cairo of
the alt left
and i was up there uh
a few years ago on this thing called
beta breakers and it's where people just
do a run like a big
run through the it's like a what does it
call where people drink water and keep
running like a marathon
marathon so it's at a marathon
and we were out there just eating
mushrooms we had a ton of mushrooms man
enough to [ __ ] really almost take you
to the next level you know you're trying
to eat that many
and uh all day i was taking pictures of
people and we just let my penis out dude
all day and all
so there's got to be at least about 150
pictures out there
from this uh festival about 15 12 years
ago where
it's just penis everywhere but uh what'd
you have your dick all the pigs
then we commandeered a water table right
people were running by and they try to
come get water and we would say no
asians only this is just for asian
people
and they were running so they couldn't
argue with us they had to keep going
like what do you what do you mean we're
like no no it's just asians but then
asian people were like oh they're cool
so you know you do what you can you do
what you can
but yeah that dick rest dick pic man i
love that dude sneak a [ __ ] d behind
your buddy's ear yeah
oh joe rogan will eat that bro
everybody kingd it
81 all right one more kinder singing and
then we'll see some culture corner
auditions damn mr steele
what's up theo what's up brandon it's
your boy boosh
what i'm saying is this dude i'm here
m-a-d-u-b-a-s-h yeah
yeah my bush
um pooping butt naked
no pulling the pants down [ __ ] you
know what i mean
no clothes at all i don't [ __ ] with that
personally i feel like i have to pull
butt naked i don't need any distractions
going on my body you know when i'm
releasing
he goes on and he explains more reasons
why my body
is telling me yeah baby
i don't wanna poop with no clothes on
i feel like it's more of a hassle taking
all your clothes off and then put it
back
yeah it's like if you're in your house
it's one thing in the middle of the
night but like where is that appropriate
when you're out to do is to get naked
and it just seems
you know who else you're out you can't
poop when you're out and about tim
yeah i'll take this [ __ ] on a plane you
absolutely can take a [ __ ] anywhere you
want
yeah that's a bear some of the best
shits are very quick shits at mcdonald's
where you look at the toilet
i have literally 20 seconds here before
i get aids
yes so you go i got to shoot so quickly
and then
some of them are just it's just like
boom boom i uh oh yeah i lived in my car
for a while right when i moved to l.a
and uh i pooped in hundreds of
mcdonald's i knew where the good ones
are
pasadena i knew that mcdonald's had
outlets from a laptop
oh some little starbucks bath did you
really just you just lived in a car for
how long
uh it was like i didn't have i wasn't on
a lease for like six months when i was
here but i worked some job
and the boss found out and he's like oh
you could stay in the warehouse so i
yeah
but sometimes i was like in my car when
they just had him crawling knocked on
the window he's like the problem is
corporate regulation yeah you're being
prevented from starting your own
business
and you're like what yeah and then he
fired save a penny miss a dollar
he turned into the man he fired you at a
holiday party uh
no it wasn't really him that's a it's a
fun podcast you do by the way
this is the adam crawl podcast ready hey
brenda how you doing
i'm good what have you been up to today
um you know castor oil everybody
make sure to go and fill up i mean it's
just it's
during the whole show like he'll be like
what do you think about donald trump
anyway valvoline it's like it's all
gearhead [ __ ] yeah
the guy just talks about just he's
making millions of dollars slinging
engine oil
and you're just sitting there like an
idiot yeah i like them but i mean it's
like there's nothing to say i love adam
you don't get them
out though you get a word out not one
word not one
all right tell me where you're gonna be
this weekend right
right hilarious you know who [ __ ] is
uh completely naked he talks about all
the time with charlemagne
oh i didn't know he seems like that he
seems like that kind of guy though
what a weird move man but animals do it
good point good point i do every morning
because i'm pretty regular and before i
shower
right that's fine we're not making this
whole episode about you i apologize yeah
yeah
i just don't think it's that weird poop
and naked but yeah don't do it but even
in the in public like taking your
clothes off when you're in a [ __ ]
starbucks
no because there's something to put them
on if there's a piece of paper to put
them on i think it's fine but i wouldn't
do it if there's nothing
there's other people waiting to go in
yeah what are they doing here
[ __ ] consider it it's your turn you
got there a starbucks bathroom in the
suburbs
that line is hot yeah it is because
there's women in there that want to go
in there crushing addy
there's people that want to go in there
and [ __ ] do all kinds of things like
there's just people who want to go into
that bathroom and just put [ __ ]
add a little fun to their coffee drink
so that bathroom line is like it is hot
by those people you mean me but do they
uh do you guys put down the
what kind of savage puts down the you
know that like the covering the shield
you [ __ ] with the shield sometimes dude
really sometimes you go
depends where you're at sometimes
there's a stain on the seat you don't
know what it is you're like has that
been there for a while how did it
cigarette what's its origin story and
you need to [ __ ] put down the
covering
the craziest to me is when you see the
burn mark on the seat
yeah that's a drug addict right
is it i don't know i've never known what
that is i like the graffiti
walls yeah i like that i'm trying to
figure it out usually
sometimes it's so bad you have to squat
above it and [ __ ] above it without
sitting down
never that's when it's really bad no
never i mean well good
you've lived a privileged life but
there's some times where like i risk it
dude there's sometimes you walk into the
bathroom and you're like
it's this is i don't want to touch it
even never well that's when the metal
whenever you have the metal floor and it
just forms into the toilet there's no
even disconnection between the floor and
the
toilet it's prison bad that's going to
be bad and that's in denver at the bus
station down what's the best toilet you
you've ever there was a in the woods
called in manhattan they have these
amazing toilets with
wood toilet seats wood
toilet seats four seasons in hawaii yeah
you'll see it
oh interesting because i'll sit on a
good toilet for an hour and a half and
i'll find out i'll read
yeah i sit on the go for an hour and a
half yeah to the point where i can
barely walk out of the hotel because i
have
so much pins and needles from blood
circulation problems oh yeah
my legs will fall asleep on a toilet for
more than about 40 minutes yeah
it gets crazy and then you're just
crawling away from your own you're just
hearing it flush you're crawling away
it's like you're in little vietnam like
your own little iwo jima yeah
just hearing the water and you're
crawling
this gentleman's into some stage of
transformation oh bill cower apparently
is upset about last night's game
uh see these are some culture corner
auditions and when theo's back at studio
maybe we'll zoom some of our favorites
and uh
kind of learn a little bit more about
them and you can help us pick here tim
we need we we're trying to bring some
new
culture into the culture corner so you
can help us when you leave we're gonna
bring two
thank you for commenting on our youtube
channel theo that drives traffic we
really appreciate it when you do that
oh really did i do that i think you
commented on the youtube channel
something on our podcast we like that
but then future commented and your
comment totally disappeared
because everyone was like oh future
commented that's a big example oh okay
yeah yeah that's a big deal
why do we want past over here when we
got this guy yeah i feel you man
i'll try to chime in a little bit more i
love your content man you're the best
dude i appreciate it who's this
you're so you're so entertaining i went
to two of your shows at uh
at zany's when you're in uh oh thank you
man i appreciate you didn't say hi
i did i saw tim i remember he was there
she brought chelsea lynn in there
yeah brought chelsea you know what
chelsea
like i get real territorial about the
snacks and i say everybody just keep an
eye on everything
i don't want to start accusing people of
things but like let's just keep an eye
on where everything is you know we got a
certain amount of chips
certain amount of cookies we got two
shows to do
let's not get crazy because we got a
bear in the campsite we got two bears in
the campsite right now
and we just got to keep watch you know i
tell my little opener my white trash dan
carney who opens for me
who theo likes because they're both like
white trash
yeah i tell him just keep an eye on this
big [ __ ]
and did he get a wheelchair i was trying
to get him that wheelchair hooked up
down in tampa
he he never got a wheelchair but then he
got covered he recovered from surgery
and got covered so
now he's just like covered for three
weeks he's been like he's just
tired and you know just [ __ ] living
in florida being tired and [ __ ] it's
like
um you know he needs to uh yeah i have
that wheelchair plug but i think it's
closer to sarasota i gotta hit him back
up about it i'm supposed to plug him up
with that dub c over there in tampa but
yeah dude your opener needs a wheelchair
no he did he wanted to go out because he
died
for surgery he wanted people to wheel
him around the bars and then he got
covered
because he's an idiot going out to bars
or whatever and i get it but it's three
three weeks he's still kind of tired and
listless and [ __ ]
you know but hey man that's what you get
that's what you get for not taking queer
seating
which cures coronavirus according to joe
rogan i called the doctor right after
that and the doctor said
there is no evidence of that and he goes
that is very damaging information to
spread
so he goes i hope you're not telling
that to a lot of people i'm like the guy
who told me that is telling two
tops 10 million people it's not a big
deal
all right bill cower what do you got
king in the sting
benim adam julian then turkum they
culture corner
katomak what and you know what my name
is julian i'm turkish
and i am
hey so what's up you know in my family
we got those slims
we got those christians i got that
mullet right now but i don't know what's
going on
and you know we actually run a coffee
business and i was wanting to put
a king in the sting label on a coffee
bag and work with you guys on it
i also want to sit in that culture
corner i'm in california i can easily
make that trip
and i want to make coffee for everyone
in the studio again my name is julian
i'm ready to go let's go what the [ __ ]
is culture corner people offering to
make coffee
no the culture corner with the with with
chappelle and cat we fired them because
you were coming in
yeah i don't need again i don't need
nine types of asians here during the
pandemic
they'll be back next week off the public
bus yeah
agreed man i think we're doing just fine
without them right now even though
they're lovely assets
i like to both they're great people
they'll be back they'll be back next
week
maybe they're young they got young blood
in their bodies yeah wait brenda goes
yeah
they're fine they've each at corona like
eight times they said that's not a good
statistic okay
they both live in like a ymca i'm like
let me just come and do this show
what i tried to do nine months ago
please
thank you thank you look we're just
trying to get that patreon money and
move to mars with rogan that's all we're
trying to do
i just want to be on at least the third
shuttle i'm not going to make the first
or second shuttle well rogan tell me he
called me last night he said freshly
fallen snow and maple syrup curious
coronavirus
so don't worry about it don't worry
about
it look i just ordered six pounds of
fresh ox anus off of the [ __ ] joe
road
and i'm ready to see my own future this
is like a young danny trejo this guy
what do you think oh yeah this sounds
like a young danny trey
a messed out dude [ __ ] eric yazzie
why don't you rip my drip wow
there's nothing to rip yeah
[Music]
not killing it much
how many native americans
listening to the show this is like the
third
i mean it's like the craziest like i i
don't even let native americans listen
to me
banned from listening to the show
this is like wendy williams on pills
dude what is even going on
here he's auditioned to be in the
culture corner
yeah yeah yeah yeah bubba he was no he's
so meant
he was speaking uh initially for the
first like 14
seconds uh and then i don't know he's
got sink my ink he said
yeah is that this guy definitely clown
my hound
that's alex right there pembroke welsh
corgi
dude i love that he has a belgian he has
the same dog
but he killed a real colonel to get it i
bet dude um this guy
obviously i remember this guy from the
patriot from the end where they help out
and i want to say look this guy has my
vote him
and those thick uh white foreign native
american brendan from our country
yeah listen i don't care how many native
americans you hook up with deal we can't
have this guy in the corner dude that
guy i'll tell you right now that guy
should not be in the same zip code as he
would want to do
that i'd be very very nervous about that
i do like he did a few points back
because he has a welsh corgi
i like that he got the whitest dog
possible yeah
to make up for the fact that he's just a
terrifying archetype of human being
he's like kind of johnny depp and
pirates of the caribbean but like
the broke native american reservation
version where he's like
ah duh give me some dip and [ __ ]
i want to drink beer at 9 00 a.m and
[ __ ] yeah cursed a white man and
here's my corgi
pirates of the christmas i love this guy
man and i'm i'm telling you first and
foremost we will have this guy in the
culture corner sometime
we need to get back to our roots brandon
beyond what you think brother
dude i don't think this guy's our roots
you know maybe your roots in north
dakota
but not ours i'm king of this thing this
guy's native americans
he does fascinate me he's a fascinating
guy something about him then
i want to know more about him yeah not
this guy i bet we could hire him to kill
jennifer lawrence as well if we want to
oh yeah yeah yeah and by the way he'd
[ __ ] it up somehow like he'd get to
their property
but he'd [ __ ] it up you know yeah yeah
all right one more culture corner
submission god i love that guy dude
hajime
nice it's japanese what up king of
distinct
boy daniel and i just want to say what's
up to theo brendan
chappelle cat nick
chin the dude that sits in the other
studio but never looks up at the camera
like it's the hot chick from junior high
school that i never even had the balls
to smile at
it's all close oh yeah the culture
corner
well my dad was born in mexico my
grandma barely spoke english
i barely speak spanish but somehow we
make it work
if that's not the definition of culture
i don't know what is
i can already see myself in the culture
corner
if you guys choose me to sit on the same
couch that has grazed
more butt cheeks than george bush senior
i'd be delighted
all i got to say is gang gang vatos
locals forever
yeah that guy was great yeah he's really
good shout out to that dustin poirier
it's really good but it's boring
like i wanted to like him it's
mind-numbingly boring and i don't care
yeah i couldn't wait for it to end so if
he went to a hollywood meeting they'd go
like they say go
hey thanks for coming in let us know
what you're working on you know
and get the [ __ ] out because that was
boring and a waste of everybody's
goddamn
bring back that meth head [ __ ] tanto
or whatever
because that up this guy sucks i like
the
i like the first guy that [ __ ] drippy
steve jobs with the mock turtleneck yeah
anyone who's better than this dude this
guy's like i'll edit my way around my
zero personality
yeah i like this uh i like this um gary
varnick hitman right here
and then i also like uh obviously
the guy that [ __ ] makes our blood in
a cauldron our little uh
our little native fella right there
right there yeah
the guy he has a drug brown brother yeah
he does dude
so what dude you look like a kind of guy
who cropped us in a room and then moon
walks back through it dude
this is a guy that's like really on
something
cool too it's like opium it's like
peyote like he's on something good
he's like something mythical like he's
just gotta pull a wolf out from behind
your ear dude this guy ain't [ __ ]
playing on that tomahawk dmt dude he
thinks theo and brendan are
two dragons to talk to him like he's
never seen you
he has no idea what your physical form
is he just thinks you're two dragons
from another dimension that speak to him
oh man that's too good is that it nick
that's it oh tim dillon you've done as
much as you could do
timmy i i really appreciate this thank
you so much
this is a always fun to do it's always
fun to do
good luck man i kept the glasses on the
whole time because theo had his glasses
on i'm just like i'm being
i'm just being [ __ ] serious right now
theo where can we watch this uh live
show you're doing with that big chick
thanks for asking man uh it is this
friday 8 p.m
and um you can get the tickets we'll put
it up in the uh in the in the bio below
it's belated christmas talent show we
got live
talent that's not good and we got real
professional talent that's going to be
performing that you've heard of and we
got
some packages we shot in advance it's
gonna be really really cool man i'm
excited about it
that's awesome dude also if you guys
could go to tim j dillon on instagram
and twitter and follow me and just wait
for instructions about how to get back
at these dykes
yes and i'm in uh san marcos texas with
a squad at the mark in san marcos texas
right outside austin i don't know where
it's at either but that's january 29th
and 30th
how do we infuse love into these lesbian
women's hearts into the dark
it's very hard how do we break them down
they're very business-like and cold
hardships they are and it's just you
know not my fault
and what are they cornell graduates or
something they're probably they probably
i don't know if they're cornell they
probably went to a hospitality program
i'd like a a st you're not a state
school but like the
a private school that's like a degree
above state school but i don't think
these are
big [ __ ] they're they're not ivy
league [ __ ]
ivy league [ __ ] don't end up in a war
with me yeah they're too
do smart for that can solve this salvage
this relationship and get them on your
podcast if john and mila are willing to
come on my show
i will be willing to have them and they
could
they can say with their piece but i mean
i think it's probably gonna have to be a
situation where i
uh kill them
i don't know if they're gonna come on
man they're probably not gonna come on
because they don't have anything
no to say for themselves yeah no [ __ ]
brendan they're not gonna go on there
brendan
yeah they're not going to come on but
that's okay i feel like i feel like
timmy's the nice guy
they make a car cars go off the road all
the time you hear about this
cars go off the road and then the people
in them die maybe they got a nut out
so weird dude leave some semen on their
coffee table that'll scare them
it's so that's true it will scare them
they'll probably put it in their
barren childless [ __ ] and come up
with a [ __ ] another insufferable [ __ ]
that's why i won't do that they're not
getting my [ __ ] semen
oh they're women chelsea
yeah so we could have a cinnamon roll as
a child
a jelly roll a jelly roll yeah oh man
tim dillon thank you so much thank you
guys
thanks for having me deal good luck with
your show brother
thank you guys brennan and theo fighter
and weight i got to go in and go hard in
the paint
i do not think i am in flow black rifle
coffee i'm ready to go i need a sponsor
i am a monster about to open up with
this at my concerts flow is contagious
browser outrageous thicker than girls
that are instagram famous damn
hungry like i'm fresh off keto seeing
red like andrew santino
every song i hit like the great bambino
burning ain't the queso in the case of
ritos
but everything's gonna be fine hate on
me i do not mind
theo looking like the type of dude that
got a pack of matches in his pockets at
all times
they sliding into my dms a couple of you
tried but couldn't beat him quit playing
like nintendo ds you don't want to smoke
like joey diaz
meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and i'm feeling
incredible
brandon son hit me up he said it's too
loud in the club can you pick me up
[Music]
got the cheese on a string